hallo leute ich ist wieder einmal war
ich hatte geburtstag und war bin ich
jetzt so alt geworden wünscht jahre halt
nein spaß ich bin 23 geworden und ich
habe richtig tolle geschenke gekriegt an
den ich aber auch gemerkt hat dass die
menschen um mich um mich vielleicht ein
bisschen zu gut und natürlich wollen
jetzt wissen was ich bekommen habe oder
eine spongebob power bank 000 katzen
sticker für die fingernägel herzens
ticker die uno spiel mit 2000 abzüge für
meine polaroidkamera die dinger sind so
scheiße teuer die hausschuhe einen
flachmann klar und das beste geschenk
sei quasi ihr und dazu gibt es ein nein
du verarscht mich mein ist nicht die
kamera die kamera hast du schon eine
ganze weile
das weiß ich nicht
natürlich ist dieses weitwinkligen bild
schon von anfang an aufgefallen ich weiß
lange rede kurzer sinn ich hatte einen
ganz wundervollen geburtstag aber auch
eine sehr lange harte dreh woche für
meine sendung band taste deshalb habe
ich für euch einen ganz vorzügliche clip
aus dieser sendung und zwei kriege ich
eine mode ins gesicht aber sie zählt
hallo leute willkommen bei buddies
beauty palace ich bin vanessa und das
ist meine make up with the stars teil
sind machen hallo ich wollte
ausprobieren wie es denn so ist eine
moschee im gesicht zu haben ich kann es
leider nicht so gut wie eine
ausgebildete waffen wienerin und deshalb
liegen jetzt auch schon los und jetzt
werde ich zur sonne
das ist der trend für den herbst 2016
weiße augenbrauen so dass ich noch nie
so doll meine augen gekümmert was machst
du gerade an
warum es dazu sagen geld ist ja meine
lieblingsfrage sehen konnte ich mein
buch ist lustig aber bananen ton
gummienten forward schilder zuvor
verpasst
was machst du denn gerade mit dem bruder
das abmontieren dass ich die zeit
getroffen und an das ist ein bisschen
das ist die farbe intensiver wird wenn
die lippische tricks und die wahrheit
viele haltbar machen möchtest du bist du
mit auflagen
warum sagt man gern tage blieben sie
auch das gefühl von blutigen lippen
kannst du auch meine nase popeln gedanke
jetzt kannst du bei dir wohnen schließen
weil ich halt
macht mir mein mac
ananas anna anna macht das sehr gut
gemacht und wie sony und jetzt beim
lebenden objekten ankommt testen wir im
reallife aufgeht
in sri lanka
uns geht's
s
das hat man super geklappt oder
hundertmal am tag nutzen wir im moment
ist aber wenn es einmal so lustig
angesicht zu angesicht gegenüber steht
ja dann interessiert uns das irgendwie
nicht naja gut was soll man machen
ich habe ja mit genauso viel spaß beim
zugucken wie ich beim drehen ganz
ehrlich gesagt ich war so aufgeregt weil
ich noch nie so was in der stadt gemacht
habe wo ich aufgefallen bin und habe ich
finde dafür bist ganz schön gut gemacht
oder wir sehen uns ganz bald wieder mit
einem mal war eine original video und
bis dahin kann es mal war